Namie back this season yeah she's
another housewife who dealt with marital
issues on the show her about how to deal
with it she's been at this a lot longer
than I have and I do definitely seek
counsel from her she did give me some
advice on you know she's been you know
near didn't forced and married again and
I think she she's rooting for us but at
the same time you know she did actually
go through a divorce so it's kind of
like well now maybe I should go through
a divorce and then I can get back here
to get to I feel like I do too but I
just see her counsel I think she
definitely is someone to be an expert
when it comes to all things reality TV
there would be no one that will be able
to feel the shoes of you need leaks with
Cynthia what's been the best piece of
advice she's given you I think the best
advice that Nene has given me now since
we've been on the show together is to
just make my own opinions about the
ladies because you know she had her own
and you know when I was new I was new
and I didn't know them and you know just
to get to know them for myself and and
then like I'm and not like I'm if I you
know whatever I choose